the number-one goal of all my college
friends from the day we started college
to the day we drive for four years later
was to get me to take one hit of one
blunt this is very important this is not
hahaha bun
this is maximally disruptive sometimes
people hit me up there Gary
have you run the businesses when you're
traveling so much it's called the phone
I don't know if you guys heard that's
what we try to get like do something
that happens like everybody knows about
it prosperity is usually the indicator
to turmoil too many people are [ __ ]
lazy because they want it too fast so
you need to figure out something you
actually like so you put in the hours
because nothing great comes easy you got
your prospective be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
my preference and I think what brings
more value is less keynote more Q&A but
um but if you guys like more keynote
less Q&A and think they need they need
your energy okay that's fine
so we'll go we'll go now we're left over
it all these I got it I always plan on
it it's my normal way of speaking on
stage now if right before I get on
they're like hey we got a conservative
crew we kiss are you not - I'm always
respectful of the route the home that
I'm entering so you know I'm a very
chorus person yes usually the first word
out of my mouth every morning is some
flavor of shade of F yes these guys are
a little more conservative yes I thought
I'd tell you that you can use it once
fair and very very thanks and you're
just gonna walk out there and say hey
everybody before I spoke I was 34 years
old when I really started speaking and
then like real life I didn't curse all
that much and then I started doing these
talks and my mom started watches like
what are you like and she was fine my
mom curses too but at some point she
pegged it she's like she called me one
day and she's like do you think
listening to Richard Pryor and Eddie
Murphy and all that stuff
when you're like a kid is why you do
that and like now when I look at my
keynotes I'm like oh my god I'm really
doing a set up there I don't know if you
could send him yeah well here let me
John yeah I've got it
John what up man it's Gary Vee listen
when you're 23 society's trying to tell
you you have to figure it out but I got
a big news for you
no 23 year old had it figured the [ __ ]
out either like you got lots of time I
think the next seven years is a good
time to go high-risk high-reward
like just live humble the only reason
kids get caught is you want to buy dumb
[ __ ] to impress other people if you
don't buy dumb [ __ ] then you can do
anything go taste things go figure out
what you like to do because the level of
hard work it takes to actually be
successful is a lot easier when you
actually like something and the reality
is too many people are [ __ ] lazy
because they want it too fast
so you need to figure out something you
actually like so you put in the hours
because nothing great comes easy
[Applause]
[Music]
when a handheld traditional like that
[Music]
Sharon gets ready for this keynote the
at the financial player viewing him at
the end of is just the initial name
banks credit unions space I'm super
comfortable with he's excited to just
kind of speak my truth given to note
just had a breakfast and there's some
great clips from there there's two or
three real good ones I'm not sure if you
yeah feeling sharp we're gonna stand up
here get ready
[Music]
outsiders robbers see ya leave now leave
the conference leave my talk go back to
the office and stop any cent spent on
banner ads on websites
it is a literal joke as much as I hate
television commercials because watch
this watch this not 16 year old crowd
you ready watch this by show of hands
how many people here now mainly watch
when they watch television Netflix Hulu
Amazon or go or when it on video on
demand and you fast-forward commercials
raise your hands Netflix
raise them high sleep keep them up I
want everybody in the front in these
fancy couches to look back look at this
keep them up for a second can we all
agree that the majority of people in
this audience aren't fourteen teenage 14
year old teenage girls this audience
almost 95% of you don't even have a
chance of seeing the commercial forget
about if you consumed it and got
inspired to do business 95% of this
older crowd is not even got a prayer of
seeing an actual television commercial
six billion dollars spent to make you
buy things in America on television
commercials
[Music]
you
if your national bank instead of
spending fifty million dollars on
television commercials and nobody sees
I'd rather go give a big-time production
company ten million dollars to be the
sponsor of a new show on Netflix called
ATM where the whole show transpires
around ATMs and it is literally your
company like actually not a made-up bank
the Ed Sullivan Show was funded and
created by the Lincoln Town Car Company
people forget that history television
started with brands funding it
commercials came later I believe now
that commercials are gonna be
disappearing because we're watching
screaming I do not I do believe that
Netflix and Hulu and Amazon will test
commercials my intuition is if they're
smart they're gonna do product
integration and I think look let me give
you another one
I've always thought that a like a big
car company with like the trucks should
do a show called the tailgate or the
whole show again is that a tailgate and
it's your truck is the family's truck
Toyota Ford and like that works was how
its if you guys watch the Masters
yesterday I matured the whole brand
placement and lack of advertising
becomes it's it's just it's amazing what
can be done or the new world we live in
on Twitter the number one thing that
people were talking about was Tiger
chewing gum and so we have a gum client
so I called him this is Sunday now you
got to move fast like hey dude do you
know like you know like like there's
multi-donor if you guys saw at one of
the awards show the Fiji water girl
right the woman Leonard I think they
called you know like that like that's
moral wit like guys nobody watches
commercials nobody goes through the
American Direct Mail carefully nobody's
going to page 37 of a magazine looking
at the ad carefully like the world has
changed I'm sorry
farming used to be our number one
industry things happen like Sears was
number one Walter Cronkite was you know
America's dad like things change I'm
sorry things changed things have changed
when you look at the shear on-premise
volume spikes because for Budweiser on
the d-wave spot its staggering and the
actual consumption of that video in
comparison to what we can get on TV sea
or billboard is incredible if you think
about if we all just sat here and
dreamed a little dream of the capability
of this brand making two and three
minute videos right multiple ones for
different segmentations with different
cultural relevance is like again you
know there's a ryu no this is not an
easy challenge by marketing standards
and it's at a time where i want to prove
something to the reason we raised our
hand is this brand more than any brand
i've come across in a while has the most
permission both again for sixty
three-year-old women in ohio and for the
culture and i think that's remarkable
and a testament to the work that's been
done now it just needs a different
execution model I just don't believe the
traditional partners you work with where
the TDC down model can pull it off I
really don't I'll be honest with you
like you're gonna add to that but I'll
be honest with you I'm willing to do
that for every goddamn piece of content
that's how much I believe that's smart
and then everybody says like gives like
four or five different titles
we got like twenty minutes to give
titles and then we run fifteen
twenty-five dollar you'll figure that
out and then we have results it could be
like a whole game for everybody like try
to be Gary yes I sure do as a matter of
fact what I'm most excited about now is
now that like I want you to like
basically make a video right now and put
it into there like hey just talk to Gary
new rule here's literally how we're
gonna do it Gary's going to thumb up a
video but Gary's gonna write a title
right from a video and then that
basically opens up 20 minutes for
anybody else to write titles and then
we're gonna run them like and and by the
way for me I'm probably gonna come up
with two or three I think what you need
to get back to me on like by the way
this is how we do it now this is done
because this is awesome it's it's volume
model it's marketing for the sake of
marketing we're gonna put out 75 I don't
know how low can you go with the ads to
give us a read in your opinion like 15
bucks 10 bucks or so let's go fifteen
times five that's our rule
we call it the $75 rule yep five titles
and then I think what we have to do is
decide how many we're gonna go against
my fans versus people that have touched
my content that are not my fans like you
know like that's the next question but
to me that's the [ __ ] framework five
[ __ ] titles then five bucks each
against my fans non fans that like
entrepreneurship or fire and five
dollars against people who touched my
content but have not followed me look at
the quant and qual pick go that's right
more more MORE taking advantage of every
time we've taken advantage of more
technology and not just my intuition
we've grown and so I need to be fed the
opt I'm not against you
I have no ego or I'd live my own truth
if I never write another headline for
myself then I wasn't good enough cool
see ya yeah it was and let me tell you
guys we just followed it we're gonna
fill this whole clip the reason to live
and now that I'm getting out of my
meeting is this is my managers lose and
bosses lose they want to be right
instead of finding right I want to find
right even if it's the expense of my own
confidence mainly because I love merit
like I want to high-five you Caleb if
you keep coming up with the headlines
that most over-index on Facebook and
Instagram that's awesome I I Drive in by
impacting people and being successful
building brand then be like living in a
cocoon of thinking I'm winning actually
winning versus thinking or winning is
the big Delta between managers and CEOs
and founders and bosses and really I'm
being successful versus really being
successful and I'm out here trying to be
really successful not even really
successful and definitely not successful
you understand
there's fun content yeah damn what up
Gary Vee listen brother
you get one that bad at this so you have
to pull from opposite directions one
you're so young right now there's an
inherent need of like what am I doing
with my life but I need to cover
something up in you happy knows how that
like success be that you you need to you
have like one you think before you about
2:00 p.m. I put two not a pressure to
figure it out like it's stunning how
many people fiction elbow 3057 hug you
like how many that little bit but had a
vision without too much of jump in on
yourself and take advantage and it's a
big point you're not it looks like a
where you got you know roof overhead
kids all that stuff comes next decades
think I'm self-aware what makes you
happy not what you think makes you happy
or what you think makes the people that
you care about around you happy all
right where we going
the last selfie I did were from your
angle like the one I did pretty other
person yeah yeah doesn't raise the
conger like just a
[Music]
such a pleasure I don't think you should
do that there's gonna be so much good
keep no you should get somebody to get
it absolutely let's ask them how are you
do you got can you got it coming the bag
thank you enjoyed it thank you hold on
one second
my bag you gotta find it do you know
where it is
who will know
you leave this out to women is appalling
them on glandon live in LA and do it how
you doing
enjoyed it thank you
[Music]
sitting here of a Vegas Airport just got
done with the financial conference met
with some of my team members from our
amazing chase client did a series of
phone calls for Vayner talent for
vaynermedia running the business from
the phone now ladies get on this flight
to LA get to LA see my good friend
Michael key bus talk a little business
head back to the hotel incredible dinner
with Juicy J to chop up some
opportunities you've seen some of the
content with me and juicy about a month
ago we're gonna continue to build on
that so that's fun to see transpire then
get some rest and then and then hit it
hard tomorrow we have a four DS daily
digital deep dive or consulting product
for a bunch of individuals in the LA
office and then I have a big event at
USC where I'll be speaking which I'm
excited about
and the series of 30 to 50 phone calls
and emails and decisions made to run the
[ __ ] X you know kind of empire in the
making as I'd like to think of that I
think a lot of people are confused on
what is actually happening on a day to
day from the executive sometimes people
hit me up to like Gary have you run the
businesses when you're traveling so much
it's called the phone I don't know if
you guys heard but you can make a lot of
decisions ecute 'iv you're in
decision-making mode right you're you're
making decisions so I you know I was on
with Jeff Nicholson our head of media
and tracer are kind of our ad tech
product and literally made like seven
decisions in 11 minutes walking through
the airport just now that a lot of
people have a one and a half hour
meeting in a conference room to get done
and Caleb's head is almost falling off
his body because I think what makes me
tick and what I think people will
analyze can learn from my people have
taken really this whole journey has a
lot to do with to do with selfishness
and selflessness right selfishly I'm
pumped in my great-grandkids for
watching this rain
trying to figure out how they want to
manage their lives they're nonprofits
their businesses and selfless I'm so
pumped right now that an entrepreneur
that's struggling and thinks that she or
he have to be in meetings or have to be
in the office you have to make decisions
whether you make those decisions on a
phone whether you do them through going
on top of the mountain and doing smoke
signals and people can understand what
you're saying
text emojis phone calls in purses
breakfast --is on planes however you
hack making decisions and putting
players in the position to succeed to be
successful and how you surround yourself
with great people I'm not in the office
I think about HR how's everybody doing
quad hits me up about something like you
can make the machine work Allen and I
made a a bit we're looking at acquiring
something
I made that decision this morning
brushing my teeth on speakerphone like
your job is to make decisions not sit in
a conference room for an hour
wasting 43 minutes to make a decision
that could have been made in 17 minutes
think about that ship
we're jewelry in our control you know
college or no college no yeah college
young see a bill in Fayetteville can't
remember a name in college but it was it
was crazy fun
oh wait a bald man I forget my age when
I was on stage I was jumping around so
he ran out of breath when I all that
wolf he slowed down there and then the
beautiful thing is he goes and showed
you how much of a hard work and
selfishness
you know is he's FaceTime you us tells
us this set up a studio session gets
made
has her doing her thing then he comes in
from the road
Hopson doesn't song and this is all you
can only do that when you love something
yeah you're right for me I mean last
night a few all the way out here to
Vegas and I'm speaking this morning had
to get up at 6:00 and was literally on
eBay for four hours yeah you're right
drew yeah it's fine man it's fine yeah I
know is going we might be tired later on
but we like sit in the classroom for 20
minutes and science class no I've never
even transferred my mom was on some
serious Nancy Reagan the number one goal
of all my college friends from the day
we started college to the day we
graduate four years later was to get me
to take one hint of one blunt they they
speed they tricked they use hot girls
they used trying to get me drunk they
eat they like they tried to like move
every move and then it became and then
it became like a meme in itself right
and then I started giving a [ __ ] the
other way
do you remember what oh you'll love this
actually you'll love this we made a
sweet I did I made a one-off song cuz I
had a sneaker with
doesn't want you to play right yeah
listen let's go and when it was done it
was like to it look we should do verses
on that mug like what you put it up
worship would birth and when it was done
do you remember this when it was done
facing day in LA in be rock Juicy J for
crew my boy
Caleb and and just regular just positive
vibes people have people people people
really good day
you